uh yes representative Hudson would you
uh everybody here
you're missing who are we missing Renee
well Renee
and oh no Allison hi Allison
um
who is Beth
okay he may be coming for the exact
session and not the work session
um So the plan is here uh for a couple
of hours to have open
um a work session on Two Bills
um one is House Bill 301 and one is
House Bill 157 I think right
um
I don't care if we set this up for an
hour or an hour for each bill
um I don't particularly I'm letting this
Freewheel we have a couple of uh guests
in the audience that would like to help
us with those bills this is a work
session so it's somewhat more informal
than a traditional hearing or anything
else like that
um I would
offer
our guests to to interact with any of
the questions that we have as we go I
still would like things coming through
the chair I don't want any crosstalk by
and large would be helpful everyone has
something interesting to say I'm going
to assume and and that should be that
should be part of the conversation so
that we can all hear what everyone is
saying but other than that
um I also wanted to point so why don't
we start with 301 I wanted to point out
the very fine work of our researcher
who has given us a
this is called a side by side for
freshmen
I think
um
what it is doing what it is giving us is
original the amendment and the
original no are they both the same
Amendment
so it's two pieces the the current law
and the amendment not the original 301.
okay
so
um
so I suspect
um we also have a third option I'm
hoping that
representative Gordon everybody knows
representative Gordon who is the chair
of uh our current chair of house ethics
and the reason that we're all here
actually because the representative
Gordon gave us the bill two years ago
that we retained and worked on over the
summer and which ultimately turned into
house bill 301. so um
why don't I ask can can you come to the
to the microphone and um
and help us uh
peace or or parts what these uh what we
have in front of us and what the
sections are that um uh were
objectionable or confusing or language
that we need to strike from the original
some of us did meet with the just to
catch everyone up some of us did meet
with the Ethics Committee uh earlier
this month
um and we heard an earful of of things
that the committee specifically didn't
like or didn't think that they could
work with
we made very good notes of of those
things and
a lot of what they told us is what has
turned into the amendment that they now
have and you now have in front of you
um
is that not correct representative
Gordon
uh
I think everything is correct I just
don't know what everybody has in front
of them is that what I sent you by you
you have you have the side by side that
um our researcher put together for you I
don't you will Mr chair you keep
referring to him as representative
Gordon
um we have car we have copies okay of
your Amendment yeah
um
okay that'd be great I thought didn't we
didn't we email that out there yes you
did
oh okay
we'll make sure everybody has that
no no you can make
um okay great
um
you have a copy of the amendment as well
I do not have a copy of your Amendment
all right so why don't we talk about
your Amendment while we're getting the
copy of the
committee Amendment um I'll call it the
sheen Amendment just because it's the
first name on it
if I could just start maybe giving you
I can't follow along with anything he's
going to say if I don't have it
why don't you start with the background
and Rich they may need a couple of
accounts good
so
what what initiated the what initially
initiated the original legislation
was an event which occurred in the
Ethics Committee and that was
first an advisory opinion and then an
informal resolution both involving the
issue of recusal when is it appropriate
for a legislator to recuse themselves
and currently under our ethics
guidelines that we have
there is no requirement specified for a
legislator to recuse themselves
when the guidelines were first created
30 years ago
30 some years ago
they were focused on the issue of
disclosure disclosing the fact when you
have a conflict
and so they addressed that issue when
you have a conflict of interest that you
need to disclose and it provides
legislators with the option
uh either continuing to participate
announcing the fact that you have a
conflict But continuing to participate
or
in the all uh or recusal so there's an
implication of recusal but no
requirement that legislators recuse
themselves
but then the legit the legislative
Ethics Committee had two cases in which
there was an obvious
conflict of interest
where someone would be making decisions
on something for which they potentially
were being compensated for doing
and
so the legislative Ethics Committee and
its informal resolution and its advisory
opinion said yes there are circumstances
when people really need to recuse
themselves
but again not specified at all in the
ethics guidelines and that's what
precipitated the original legislation to
say hey
there are circumstances under which
legislators should recuse themselves and
there are a couple of reasons for that
one is because our constitution has some
provision in regard to that and second
is because you want to maintain the
confidence of the public
the PO I think an ordinary citizen would
expect
that a legislator would not be voting on
things where they were going to be
receiving a direct Financial benefit
that just makes sense
so
that's what precipitated the original
legislation and that legislation has
gone uh it there was an initial bill two
sessions ago that died in the covid
process there was one in the last
session which we retained and that's
uh chairman Hill to his credit came to
the Ethics Committee and said uh he came
up with a proposal and the amendment
that you that the the committee
amendment that you have and came to the
Ethics Committee and said you know I
would like your thoughts with regard to
that as the committee
uh discussed that
and I have to say that the committee
hasn't come to any type of resolution
because the committee has various ideas
there are two things which I think the
committee is in agreement with and I
think most people are in agreement with
there are circumstances when legislators
should recuse themselves I think
everybody agrees to that and and two
particular circumstances
one is when you're going to get some
particular benefit
as a result of your employment or the
organization of which you're a part of
you're going to get some particular
benefit from and the particular example
for that is representative uh we had an
informal resolution involving
representative lay uh God Rest his soul
now who's since deceased but
representative lay was a a acting as the
president of a teachers union
but then voting on issues which involved
raises for teachers for example or
issues with regard to teachers
and the question was was that ethical
for him to do that and the Ethics
Committee determined it wasn't
but the issue of course for the Ethics
Committee at the time was the ethics
guidelines doesn't say anything about it
but so we issued an informal resolution
which he agreed to to his credit that
said yeah I probably shouldn't be doing
that and I'm not going to do it anymore
that doesn't mean that he shouldn't be
uh
uh voting on issues that involve
teachers all together or education
altogether but something that would
affect directly benefit his membership
of his union he shouldn't be doing we
all agree that lobbyists should not be
voting on things that would affect their
clients right
but there's nothing in the ethics
guidelines that says you can't do that
right now
so those are things that we agree in the
second thing we agree on is that
sometimes legislators may find
themselves voting on legislation that
has a direct Financial benefit to them
and just to use an example
is the frm legislation last year and the
frm legislation if you have a legislator
who is potentially going to get tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars as a result of that legislation
they probably shouldn't be voting on and
to the one legislator who did have that
circumstance did recuse themselves last
year just to point that out
but there ought to be some provision
that says you shouldn't be voting on it
so the reason that the so the Ethics
Committee agrees to those I think
generally agreement among the Ethics
Committee members the issue though is to
what ex how do you define that and to
what extent do you put that into law
because uh
and you know just
there's
uh Constitutional Amendment
there's a excuse me there's a
constitutional provision in our
constitution right now which is part of
the bill and the findings it says that
part one of the Constitution says no
member of the general court shall take
fees be of counsel or act as an advocate
in any cause before either branch of the
legislature well how do you define act
as an advocate
because we all advocate for our
constituents right so it has to have
more meaning than that God knows and and
it's not for us to interpret that as for
the for the courts to interpret what
that would mean they interpret the
Constitution
so but long and short it must have some
connection to you getting some benefit
you you're a stakeholder in some way and
either you're getting paid or you're a
member of an organization whatever and
you're getting some benefit so
we look at that and say well uh if we're
going to set some type of definition it
has to be in a way that the
the legislator is going to be receiving
some type of benefit as a result
and but acting on behalf of someone else
some organization
an employer or someone else
the second issue is with regard to
legislators
frm is a great example because of the
amount of money involved
but
just last week there was legislation
about uh
one retiree in the legislature recuse
themselves
one filed a notice of intent saying
they're going to participate anyway
and there were probably other people who
now for state and retiree in all
likelihood
that legislation would result in
literally thousands of dollars each year
to them and over a course of time
tens of thousands of dollars so should
they be voting and that's the question
you know that's the really difficult
question that the Ethics Committee has
tried to wrestle with and that is where
you'd draw that line
and so the Ethics Committee really can't
because there are there's at least one
member of the Ethics Committee that says
hey I really don't want to have to deal
with that you know uh how I let's just
keep it the way it is because
um the the fact is that if we try to
apply that standard it's going to be
more work than it's worth you know so
that's where that's sort of where the
Ethics Committee is so while I'm
appearing today and I'm not appearing
representing the Ethics Committee I'm
representing myself in doing this today
so the proposal that I had
just addressed to if you have that in
front of you just address those two
issues that I mentioned
recusals for conflicts of interest
one that legislators would recuse
themselves from voting on any
legislation one of the things that the
committee did look at was
what does recu what does what should be
required in recusal
currently in the current guidelines
recusal requires you to refrain from
participating in any activity
and
so one of the things that said if we're
going to have a standard the standard
should be how you know if somebody talks
to somebody else while they're in the
bathroom
does that kind have you violated your
provisions
so to make it clear what we've said is
recusal should be from voting
so that for example in the frm case the
person who has an interest could speak
to other legislators
but couldn't vote on the issue in
committee or couldn't vote on the issue
in uh
on the session in session
so every voting on any legislation when
the legislator or a member of the
legislator's household is employed by or
is acting as an agent for an
organization whether for-profit or
non-profit and this is a two-prong test
one in which the organization is the
subject of the legislation and the
organization or its membership has a
special interest as defined in the
current Statute in the outcome of the
legislation
so it's got to be more than just an
outcome so if you were on the board of a
hospital for example and there should be
an issue with regard to Medicaid rates
if
the first prong the test says well
is that hospital the subject of the
legislation well no Medicaid rates are
for everybody
so even though they would affect the
hospital it wouldn't affect your
hospital any more than it would anybody
else
so in that particular case uh it
wouldn't but if but if you got to a
point where you were voting on whether
your hospital should be able to merge
then I think you are the subject of the
legislation and you would be affected
and you would have a special interest so
this sort of a two-prong test as to
whether or not recusal should take place
so
in the Douglas case for example
if the issue is over whether teachers
should get
cost of living increases
uh
uh then or raises that's one thing if
it's a question
but if it's a question over whether
there should be Freedom savings accounts
or educational savings accounts that's
another question he probably could vote
on educational savings accounts because
it doesn't affect his union members
directly
so
and then the second provision would be
legislative should recuse themselves
from voting on any legislation when a
legislator or a member of the
legislators household may receive a
direct Financial benefit or detriment as
an outcome and then direct Financial
benefit is further defined which means
that it could be reasonably expected to
have a direct and substantial effect on
the income of the legislator and the
income of the legislator so it would be
Financial only and to have a direct and
substantial effect
I think if you were to apply that
standard today
uh you on the vote for raises for
retirees and you were retirees that
would require you to recuse yourself I
know when I voted on it last year my
wife is a state retiree when I voted on
it uh when I when it came before the
legislature last year I recuse myself
and there were a number of other people
that did recuse themselves so that was I
was surprised this year when not many
people did but I think that's indicative
of not understanding the
the process or or looking at it from a
different standpoint why don't we take
can we take
um I think we need to take this in steps
and and pieces as we go so what I would
like to propose is
um armed with
um
the the side by side and I'm looking
specifically at page two
um
and
what is called 14 C 4 a recusal and
disclosure for conflicts of interest
um
seems to line up with
honorable Gordon's 14
Dash C 3B recusal for conflicts of
interest
uh
I guess what I'm starting with is
how far from that legislator
does this
um interest lie how and I go by the
concentric Circle theory if we start
with the the legislator in the middle
how far out from that
um in in your
proposal you talk about the legislator a
member of the legislator's household
is employed by or acting as an agent for
an organization
um
and that's it
in in the amendment
um the the sheen Amendment it talks
about the legislature recuse himself or
herself from voting in any official
legislative activity when the legislator
or any person living in the household
with the legislator or financially
dependent on the legislator
so
markedly different 301
the original 301 expanded it even
further which Ethics Committee was not
in favor of that talked about anyone
that the legislator cares about
um
and and that seemed to be
caused them consternation because they
didn't have any way of determining who
that person would be
and I should perhaps step back and and
make it clear that in drafting 301
it was my intention to to draft it from
the standpoint of a legislator not the
standpoint of the Ethics Committee
um
I was looking at it from the standpoint
of advising
all of our colleagues that sit in reps
Hall and are having to decide whether an
issue arises that they need to go down
and see our Clerk and say I'm not voting
on this issue
what happens after that
personally I don't care
um I that's that's for the Ethics
Committee to decide but for me I'm
trying to make sure that this purple
book that's handed out to everyone
gives
honest guide guidance to those those
Representatives so when I was saying
someone you care about
I think it's up to each individual rep
to decide who it is that influences your
vote
so I understand it didn't fit the legal
definition and and that's not my problem
um I uh I'm trying to not get it to the
Ethics Committee I'm trying to to have
be the brotherly advice to our
legislator friends to say this is what I
think you should do or that's what this
is what um we have decided that would be
the the correct pathway so
what does the committee feel about
um that idea of concentric circles what
what's your there's also another option
I think
um Allison you provided us a another
view of that
um uh yeah at our last Works work
session I had an amendment and I just
made sure everyone still had a copy of
it
so we have that as well that yep that's
the
I'm going to call it the Allison because
it's true I don't know I feel like the
I don't know do you have a copy did you
receive a copy of the nutting Wong
Amendment yes okay
so
what
um
if you're looking for an opinion on the
nutting Wong concept I'm looking for
a an opinion on
um
which of these or are any of these
suitable to what we want to do from your
perspective well having been at the
meeting that you are at with the
in front of the Ethics Committee I think
what I took from that meeting was
um go slow that's what I took out of
that so what does that mean to you is it
in terms of these three uh it means that
I think they
nutting along Amendment
fits fits in the interest of going slow
um
there's
uh actually I take that back so so the
nutting Wong doesn't deal with
I I'm
incorrect that's dealing with the
definition of conflict of interest it's
not dealing with the who
of of
whether it's just the legislator whether
it's the legislator and family it's
that's dealing more with the definition
of conflict the definition of conflict
of interest
um in in the bill itself was it is
that's where it was we haven't got there
yet I think I think we need to deal with
who who would have the conflict of
interest first and then we'll deal with
the definition of what the conflict of
interest is well it's part of it
because I have that it's for themselves
or another individual
available for otherwise similarly
yep
um so maybe it's just a little bit of a
misplacement maybe that should go up to
where the
the
who is right if if conflicts of interest
if this is what if that is your
intention is to incorporate the who
um maybe we just have to move it
it would go down in the definition
section more than anything else I think
but but getting back to rep Pearson what
um as far as the
we're I think we're all agreed that the
legislator
is is part of this right
um do we then go to the legislator
um
and and one offers the
um the legislator or any person living
in the household with the legislator
um or member of the legislator's
household which is basically the same
thing
um
and then another and and then it adds in
the person living in the household with
the legislator or financially dependent
on the legislator what
I don't want to go much past household
that seems to be a very common
definition you see that in other places
going down a journey beyond the the four
walls you're going to start we're going
to get into this whole interpretable
problem that we had before so what if
you have someone that is um that is
bicostal
um or not living in the household but
but financially dependent so a a spouse
that doesn't live in that household if
your spouse doesn't live in your
household you've got bigger problems
than being a legislator
um
maybe so but that's not
um and don't be looking at me when you
say that
um what I'm what I'm suggesting is that
there are situations where
um
you would be in or you could very well
be influenced by someone that may not
live in your household but you are you
are financially responsible for say say
you have a a child that has special
needs that lives away in a in a
different place
um you know other than your household
you still are responsible for that child
um should that not be included in that
the concept of a dependent is not that
big a stretch so I mean it you couldn't
you could make a fair case
for that
um
but that's really
everything beyond that is a journey that
yeah I agree with you I don't think we
should be going down anyone else
disagree with that or yep comment
I have two adult daughters that live
with us my husband and I
um they're financially independent file
their own tax returns don't rely on
anything from us other than the roof
over their head which they pay rent for
their own groceries all of that stuff so
um do I care about them of course does
he care about them of course so they
would they would fit into this as living
in your household
but if legislation was to come down the
pike and maybe it affects
veterinary medicine or X-ray techs which
is they both are
um
in in theory with this I need to recuse
myself but they don't financially depend
on either of my husband or I
um so where does it end they move out
and they live next door
so rent a room for my neighbor
um
do I need to recuse myself because I
care about them they're directly tied to
me
I'm gonna vote on something that affects
their livelihood but would you so let me
ask if if there were recusal would you
recuse yourself on something that came
up that was regarding that issue I I
suppose that um
the proper guy
could
I could make the
appropriate decision does it impact
me in my household under my roof
directly is that the intent of this does
it impact my financial situation
directly or
um am I supposed to now look at
all of these circular
relationships oh let's say they moved on
and moved next door I don't think we go
beyond I I agree with rep Pearson that I
don't think I want to go past that point
underneath my roof is where it ends yes
um
that's
right whichever one you you think I I'm
I'm looking at trying to determine I'm
asking where everyone is the text of the
bill is is it underneath my roof or does
it have to go out further than that my
mother Florida you know like my sister
about lives in Manchester
under this bill it's if you pay if your
financial if your mother is financially
dependent on you I guess okay
but but I think where maybe you're a
little bit off is on on when you would
need to recuse yourself but just because
um with a piece of legislation may have
some effect doesn't mean that you have
to refuse yourself it's like it would
come on a Case by case and on a on a
specific Bill if it would outsize if
your child was living under your roof
and say it had a direct personal benefit
that let's say a vet tech wouldn't have
otherwise then yes you would need to
recuse yourself if it was just a general
uh animal rights build or something like
this or you know something that a
regulation that all that text would have
to do then you then entering my license
to be a vet tech for example not
requiring I would say that would be
personal opinion direct benefit you'd
have to recuse yourself
um because or detriment right you could
say detriment yeah the other case would
be if it influenced your vote to go the
other way meaning if you were in favor
of this but you're you're
someone living in your household you
know sort of convinced you to go the
other way just because it would affect
them then you would need to recuse
yourself if it would not affect your
vote in any way right because there's
um so I think it's a nuanced case it's
not it's again it comes down to the the
legislator themselves and how that feels
one thing
for example the retirees that you spoke
about that voted
if those retirees were getting the same
benefit as every other retiree
of in the state pension plan then yes as
far as ethical ethics go they can vote
if they were going to get an above
average benefit over all other retirees
let's say simply because they're a
legislator whatever
then no they shouldn't be but that's not
dealing with how far out it is a
question it's if your spouse was or if
someone is living in your right in your
household that's what we're trying to
work on but some of the stuff that's
been said
all right
implies that even somebody in your
household if they're going to get a
benefit uh they shouldn't they should
recuse themselves and no only if they're
going to get
more benefit than anybody else and I'm
willing to have that discussion but for
right now I'd like to stay on this idea
of where
where we go from how far away from that
legislation and as far as these go
either
the one you presented first or the
amendment yeah or the amendment
or both of them or this or this new
ethics both of them have cement legal
difficulties
one uh in the so-called Xi'an Amendment
uh dependent
on okay a lawyer is going to have a
field day with that if it comes to that
uh in a challenge uh same thing with
cares for in the original 301. lawyers
going to have a field day with it I do
not believe that there is a single word
in the English language
that is going to fit in either instance
that a lawyer cannot challenge
well we already have don't we already
have Financial dependent
in the statute now
no
guest household member you not you say
and it also incla includes special
interests which I'm I'm I'm not a fan of
but that's but I'm still trying to get
on this how far and you'd you would
think this is the easiest question we
have today
um how far from the legislator
if we're if we're looking at
if what we're saying here is is really
pretty much what's on page 36.
and it seems to be
in in the in the Gordon Amendment no but
I mean in any in anything is what this
with four amendments in front of me
we're doing a rewrite that's that's
what's happening here so the
if we're discussing that the the bound
rate because we're geographical here if
we're discussing what the the barriers
the walls whatever it is we're gonna how
far out you're gonna go if what's on
page 36 is pretty much what we're
agreeing to right now then let's just
it doesn't need to change is everybody
happy with I guess it's uh Romans 6 on
look
it's the tightest definition it's
um it's the tightest definition we're
gonna get which is already and basically
already there it's it's the tightest
um
the
so am I like that's it's fine with me is
a but
um
I would say I I would like conceptually
I would like to go wrong further to you
know people that aren't necessarily in
the household but but like I said we
come
I see the I see The Other Side of Heaven
language that's difficult to get that on
paper and Concepts I understand it but
putting that in words I think the
nodding long does pretty good Amendment
does a pretty good job of that not not
properly available for otherwise
similarly situated individuals uh is a
probably the best attempt at going
see I I would disagree with um
representative Pearson I don't think I
think this one is a little bit expanding
of the definition then then
um and I I like it yeah um
that
not properly available for otherwise
similarly situated individuals it's
pretty good
um but if if you were forcing my hand to
say oh you know to get something through
or are you okay with just this
definition yeah yeah I'm fine with it
yes Terry I I can tell you that one of
the things that the Ethics Committee did
agree on was uh retaining the current
definition the household definition and
that and and I think the the reason for
that ultimately is uh
because you you and the committee have
different perspectives in terms you have
a perspective of this is a guideline for
people
the Ethics Committee looks at this as a
code of conduct
and it's and is your piece a code of con
is that well the whole the whole
guideline book we we call it a guideline
because that's what we've defined it as
but I can tell you every other state
that has something similar calls it a
code of conduct and the reason and and
the reason that it's more than a
guideline is that there are penalties
for people if they don't comply and
we've we've had one person for example
who's pleaded guilty to a misdemeanor
for violating these rules
so we want to make it as clear and as
definable as possible and I think if you
contain it to household member
then then you know that's somebody that
lives in the same house is definable as
I wouldn't have any problem leaving it
as Romans 6 does
yes
I believe we need to leave it as we have
it on page 36 Roman numeral six
because you have to take it a little
further than just living in the
household you have to read the whole
thing someone has a common interest in
the expenses of daily living I think
that that extension of household member
is critically important and that's why I
want to keep the same definition but
that expands it beyond that definable
who lives in your household
I think we're familiar with the current
definition so I if
okay
um
so then we go from there
into maybe this is where
um the other half or the other part of
the idea of conflict of interest
they all seem to have
I don't know is anyone going to say they
the same concept in different language
is is it a distinction without a
difference here what are you comparing
so I'm trying to compare all of them but
from the standpoint
um the original 301 as well as the
amendment deals with
recusal and disclosure differently it
deals with disclosure
um in order to represent your
constituents
when you want to participate in
committee or debate on the floor but
and I'm not sure if and and it seems
that the amendment the Gordon Amendment
I'll call it rather than the ethics
Amendment but the Gordon Amendment also
says legislators shall recuse from
voting
on any legislation when the legislator
or a member of the legislative's
household
shall receive a direct Financial benefit
so
are we okay with the idea that of two
levels where
um one is
a verbal disclosure when you are
testifying or debating
and a and a recusal
that's different than what we currently
have and that's what places recusal in
our
in our vernacular
and I'm and I'm
um delinquent here I uh at one point
um represent uh Paul Smith asked if he
would had something to say and I forgot
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
uh join my my friend the former member
from Bristol up here in talking about a
little bit about this um as well
especially in terms of the disclosure
recusal good timing and then sort of the
the generalities and and specifically
representative Tierney's point a few
minutes ago in representative koscibles
so there's there's a lot going on here
that affects the the operation on the
floor and in our house rules as well uh
because as you know uh our house rules
do deal with Declaration of intent and
and how that is affected as well at the
committee level
um I do want to I do want to point out a
couple of things specific to the point
of recusal and disclosure uh last week
was a perfect example there was a um a
constitutional amendment concurrent
resolution raising the judicial uh age
limit from 70 to 75 and that was
sponsored by the former Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court now he disclosed in
his testimony on the floor that he would
not benefit from it because of the
retroactive nature of our constitution
but more especially that even if this
were to be enrolled and we didn't have
that issue of retrospectivity uh that
that he would be past 75 at that point
so um it it was good that he disclosed
that
um in that General sense but there are
other issues here at play as well and I
I want to address something specifically
because frm is a perfect example two
years ago
um
in the state budget excuse me does
everybody know frm that conversation
um yeah real quick can you give a real
quick or do you want me to I'll let you
handle that
um it's not a real quick subject so um
there there were
um there was a financial services firm
and and a number of people in New
Hampshire lost money with this financial
services firm
um there was a and and through Court
through a number of things there was
fault
um adjudicated and ultimately the
legislature created a fund
um to repay some of the obligations of
the frm customers and we did have I
don't know how many but we had at least
one legislator that benefited from that
that
um
refund or something so that's not really
great and that specific point Mr
chairman I I would mention that when
that when that came up in the budget
last year which which was uh a different
sort of way to handle it
um the the issue there was a floor
Amendment drafted to remove that from
the budget and the specific member that
you're referencing did declare a
conflict of interest and did not
participate on that Amendment
and further
did participate on the underlying Bill
the the final action of the bill which
in my opinion at the time uh because the
member did speak with me I suggested was
appropriate because you can't you can't
vote on a uh a 10 billion dollar budget
um and that affects the entire state
with everything else without you know
dealing with that part it was proper for
him to recuse himself on that Amendment
because it directly did benefit him from
him
and and to representative Tierney's
point that he was Raising earlier that
has always sort of been uh in in my
dealings with ethics over the years
which have been numerous that was sort
of always the the the understanding and
what I spoke with members because I will
be honest with you a lot of times and if
if some of you have filed uh with me on
the floor before
it usually happens at the last minute
it usually happens that a member comes
up to me 30 seconds before the vote on
the bill saying I can't vote on this
uh and and with with
I try to have a quick conversation with
them and and generally it's me usually
pushing the form at them and saying okay
fill this out and we'll move on uh but
the question is raise a lot do you
benefit directly from this more than
anybody else here
more than anybody else in your situation
and that has always been our our line
that that and and that if that line has
changed then that's a different story
but that was the that was the line
um specifically last week we had a
situation uh regarding the the uh
retirement benefit the the way that bill
was drafted however it there was an
impact if you were above a certain
amount
it wouldn't impact you if you were below
a certain amount it would and there were
people uh that came up to me and asked
about that
and said oh never mind I'm in this it's
the group two retirees as you could
probably imagine
um I'm above this this portion here so
it wouldn't affect me and there would be
on the other side so so yes there
probably were some folks in the room but
the question is one does it affect you
more than anybody else in the room
um additionally we do have a
representative whose wife sits
on the bench in a court and he did
recuse himself on that cacr uh uh
respective to the um the judicial term
limits so it is it is a fine line uh and
it always has been a fine line and we've
I've tried to work collaboratively with
my friends on ethics and and not just on
this issue but but other issues as well
over the years uh but but the but the
point of of conflict of interest is such
that even in our rules at the committee
level if you file a declaration of
intent in my office that's the life of
the bill so we put it in the system that
you're never going to vote on that bill
even if it comes back for concurrence
and the bill has been completely gutted
by the Senate
um you filed the conflict on the life of
that bill but it also affects you at the
committee level such in our rules that
if you've declared a conflict of
interest on a bill that's before your
committee you don't even count towards
the Quorum purposes for that vote on
that bill and that's in our house rules
problem is no one knows that you know um
no one
you know it it
my analogy is people say all the time
well it's on the doe website great right
but nobody has the ability without
um you know two months of work to and
and as you say you have 30 seconds to
make this decision right what we're what
we're trying to do
is get to the point where we have a
workable
um not fine line decision where
it's much easier for someone sitting in
rep soil with 30 seconds to just
um and and we've talked about at some
point even a decision tree thing to just
say this this this okay then you should
recuse
um I don't know if would ever get to
that point because there are all of with
400 reps there are 400 extenuating
circumstances uh probably 405 but it is
um it is our hope that by taking each of
these sections individually and and as
rep Pearson said you know a rewrite
so that it is
a melding of each suggestion
um whether it's from the guideline
standpoint or or the uh
the code of ethics standpoint I'll call
it
um there has to be some way that we make
this better than
than just being able to say well it's in
there and you should know that and to
that point Mr chairman I I
wholeheartedly agree I think
part of the issue in in the decision
tree idea is fantastic if we even if we
give them a instead of a 40 page
document a laminated card I love
yourself these 10 questions if you
answer yes to three of these then file
um but but the point is that too that it
is it is problematic you know we we
publish our calendars with reports the
Thursday before the session and and
oftentimes as I said you know 30 seconds
before the bill or as debate is being
ended I can't vote on this it is it is
appropriate especially if if I've got a
hundred people that are coming up at the
same time on that it's going to be
problematic in in getting that
implemented quickly because as you know
the speaker also reads once the vote is
is tallied the speaker also reads who
did not it would be proud
um there is I'm told just uh
tangentially to all of this I'm told
that the way our voting system is set up
with the red white and green that it
would be possible no
no we're not we're not set up for we're
not set up for a change at this point to
to to do that electronically without
substantial resources to change the
entire electronic system and button
system so that would be a an expense to
do that
what what I was going to say sorry
um was that that something as simple as
being able to stay in your seat because
as we know if you're in the middle
um sometimes it's impossible to get to
your desk in 30 seconds
um but something as simple as being able
to double toggle the the white button
would would register on your screen and
be able to say that's why you don't have
to call out their name
and then know that they have to come
down and fill out paperwork after that
that was I'm glad no but I am glad you
brought this up because I want to
explain how the voting system works uh
the white button turns your station off
and on
um and if it toggles uh which it
frequently does because members don't
always have their buttons on at the
appropriate time or vice versa
um and and so by doing something like
that uh and and as some of you know some
people wait until the very till it says
one second left to actually register
their vote
um that you know that that does create a
little bit of of a problem but we are we
don't really have it set up no I
understand that but we also do have you
know unless you change the statute about
the way you file these Declarations of
intent all of those all of those have to
be filed and we scan all of those in and
they get updated on the website Etc so
um you know it would still that right
that physical component still has to
happen but also the way it's displayed
when somebody is recused
they show up on my screen blue as
opposed to Yellow which means their
station is on versus black which means
it's not so that's how I know by the way
if you're if you haven't voted I look at
the and look at the yellow seats as
opposed to the green and reds yep and if
the yellow seat if the person's there
then I call their name but if they've
already recused and this is important if
they've already recused we've entered
them into our system as recused and they
show up blue and I don't call their name
so that's that's the physical logistic
if you will I'm good any questions for
nope you good yep
um I appreciate the uh
the Back stories here
um I think
our goal is to still provide legislation
and I think our goal is to still
work with I think the best solution and
I may be wrong I think the best solution
is to take as much as we can individual
um parts that make sense to us and and
Cobble them together into
um
an offering that we bring to the house
and say Here's how we think we add in
recusal and try not to Tamper as much as
possible with any of the existing
framework I certainly don't want to play
with the buttons
um but I but I think it is necessary
that we have a different
system than trying to make that decision
in 30 seconds and
fill out the correct paperwork in that
time period and all of those things that
is my I do have a question
yeah could I add just one more thing to
the greater picture Mr chairman I I you
know we've experienced a lot in this in
this Committee in the last 15 years uh
you know several years ago in in the
election after 2010 a member uh was the
executive director of a State political
party and this committee at the time
looked into whether or not that violated
the section of the Constitution that uh
chairman Gordon mentioned and at the
time it was determined that they did not
however several years later a member of
the house uh signed in as representing a
group and not himself as his as his
office as representative from Merrimack
whatever he signed in as a board member
of a uh political on the blue sheets or
something
and and this raised a serious question
at the time if that did uh violate that
constitutional section that we we've
discussed so I do think some some
clarification while we're talking about
this globally would would help ratify
that uh and rectify that in the future
I'm sorry representative Pearson happy
you just got me thinking about
forms and buttons and things of that
nature in the in the interest of
time and the moment is it possible for a
member to take a walk and then fill the
form out after
that way they've they haven't voted
because they're like this is going to be
a problem
and rather than holding up the process
they take a walk and then just fill out
it at you know you know what I'm saying
so I I will tell you from from a
historical perspective as recently as
three weeks ago a member came up and and
rather than be in the room so so the
member did fill out the paperwork
um and as the voting was about to begin
the member left the room so it it didn't
he didn't even actually you know remain
in his seat but we did you know still
state that the member did not
participate so he did take a walk in
that in that perspective uh physically
but he was still excused for the vote
um in the sense that if if they're
running out of time if they're coming up
at that last second and and they they
can certainly do that and I will
um you know because of the situation we
will excuse that vote uh and for the
record you know if you look at your
voting records online there are three
things that show up voting yes or no or
not voting not used or no not voting
excused
um and the when when you filed a
conflict or if you've called my office
ahead of time because you're sick that
day it will always show up as not voting
excused it's the same um with a conflict
as well so
almost
I will never tell a member to take a
walk it
sure but what I'm what so if the member
takes a walk can they come to your
office after session and fill out the
recusal paperwork that suggests that
that's that that's not appropriate
that's not a good tactic I think I think
that the member you know if if they
recognize in the moments what what's
happening if if oh oh no all of a sudden
uh yes my my spouse is going to benefit
from this uh I I shouldn't participate
and they're you know
I will
in the moment you know if they're if
they're getting up out of their seat to
come or to to leave then I think that's
the appropriate time
um
again I think the goal here is to let
people know as far and I really don't
know how to do this uh more than we
already do by publishing the calendars
with as much notice as we have them
um but please take a look through the
bills and see if you have a conflict
um and notify us as soon as possible so
that we can input and I will note just
as well that there have been bills on
the consent calendar before where
there's been a conflict and so somebody
has filed a conflict and what that means
is you don't actually because you know
we adopt the consent calendar in one
vote uh what that means is
at the end of that vote with the speaker
would say uh representative Hill
declared a conflict on this bill and did
not participate on the vote on the whole
consent calendar so um you know that
that is happening
if we're losing you I have one thing
that I would like you to be in the room
for um
yeah sure yeah I have to leave at
quarter past too and I'm sorry for that
but quarter past
yeah
but I just want to make a call first of
all
in terms of that code of conduct that we
have we've the legislative Ethics
Committee has been in effect for roughly
30 years now
and I think on six occasions we've
actually issued formal punishments I can
be corrected but I think that's right in
30 years so the Ethics Committee is not
a police force going out looking for
violations and it's not looking to
punish people it's doing in essence what
you're looking for representative Hill
and that is to have people just do the
right thing and that's well which is to
your point which is why I asked for and
I wish there were more people that did
this
um I asked for the opinion
in the in the effort to ask permission
rather than forgiveness
um
I was hoping that that would provide
some kind of guidance
um in the future for how things I think
it almost precipitated
more of a problem than than created a
I
frankly I think that in large part
that's why we're here is because we
found ourselves dealing with this issue
of recusal
and no provision for recusal at all in
the ethics guidelines and now we're here
attempting so why is it so difficult for
us to just put that one word in here
when all and and to me
that's why I keep coming back to this
idea
um as I pull this string and the and the
ball starts getting bigger and bigger
um it seems that if we allowed the
verbal disclosure
for purposes of representing your
constituents but
simply defaulted
to recusal almost as a safe harbor for
for a rep to know that that would give
them
cover from a from any kind of real well
what do you say here real or apparent
financial interest
there was a word we put in here in the
original 301 that said perceived
financial interest and that was
objected to by the Ethics Committee but
but we do talk about apparent improper
influences and and so I would suggest
that that word could change to a parent
but but I would think from the
standpoint of a representative wanting
to
um alleviate his con his or her concern
that they would be a complaint lodged
against him that the Safe Harbor would
be to
um
to recuse and there shouldn't be any
resistance to a representative wanting
to do that is my is my personal opinion
I don't know that's that's where I'm
coming from
um there was one section in that same
piece that I want you both to to be
aware of or talk to
um and that is 14 C 4 C in the original
301 it talks to exclusions for recusal
of conflict of interest and that's
that's what you were talking about
um with
uh the budget bill for instance
um
the more I look at the line that I
thought was brilliant when we first put
it in I I the less I like it as we go
um
which is probably the true nature of uh
politics here but
um it does seem to me that the
restriction on voting shall not apply to
budget and General Revenue bills I think
we can agree on that
what I'm proposing is that we eliminate
the
the next part that I think was dancing
on the head of a pin
um because that talk to bills of such
great interest where a large percentage
of the members would be affected as to
cause a problem with Quorum in the
committee or full legislative bodies
if we eliminate that sentence
is that would that be more
acceptable to the group or should there
be a fix to that group and and
where does where would use as chair of
the Ethics Committee come down on that
and where would the house clerk come
down on that that idea that
this is this is one of those areas that
isn't in the budget perhaps but
um but a large number of people
um have that problem or have that
situation
I'm trying to think of a circumstance
when that would happen
um well
um
that it's not in the budget and it's not
a general well um we're we're a large
number of legislators would have that is
common use
um current use sorry would that uh we
we've already determined that you don't
have to be you have to declare a
conflict for current use but you and
generally taxation matters in general
aren't affected current use we've said
that you probably have to declare a
conflict but not recuse and then there's
a specific opinion on that and and when
they talk about General Revenue bills
are they should they also be talking
about General expense bills or is that
not
Statewide property tax or something like
that
yeah I mean
no I I don't think taxation is going to
affect everyone in general so that would
be revenue and that would be an
automatic exclusion as far as I can as I
read this
so so that sentence could as far as
you're concerned could come out
completely and we wouldn't run into an
issue where you can't think of an
example where okay is that true for you
um anybody else have a comment on that
piece if we if we lost that whole
sentence would be okay with me you're
talking about 14 c4c yes in its entirety
no just a second after the word or the
word bills right
General Revenue bills right so or and
then get from oron yes sure okay or on
yeah
um
I think that causes more problems than
it fixes
um Mr chairman yeah the last thing I
just wanted to mention of um the
chairman chairman Gordon mentioned um
punishment per se
um keep in mind uh he mentioned the the
member that that that pled guilty to a
misdemeanor however the committee it
also does have the ability to recommend
to the full legislature to the Full
House and to the full Senate
um the the three inherent uh punishments
that the house has the ability to
implement which are reprimand Center and
expulsion
um and they have made recommendations in
the past to the body uh in those regards
in those but those powers do inherently
lie with the legislature so that's why
um it's just important to note that as
well that those nothing nothing in any
of these have any influences on any of
that for us as far as but they could
certainly make that recommendation and
you know they if they had opted right in
the case of of Representative lay to to
make that motion than a member of the
Ethics Committee would have brought that
on the floor okay
yep I have to go but one the other thing
is uh
and my ignorance about this may impact
the house rules as well yeah right now
with the way it appears is uh uh 30 days
after passage I think at least in the
amendment and perhaps it should go into
effect at the beginning of the next
session
that's probably a great idea anyone have
a objection to that or a comment on that
um
next
great I appreciate that thanks thank you
yes yeah yeah you're good
um any other comments that anyone has
while we're before we move on to the
next section are we still on geography
or have we settled that the household
of how far away from the legislator yeah
it sounds like we've settled that just
to leave it alone did by leaving it
alone okay and submit and and to my
point of view taking that language and
and
um placing it
inside the existing form
um
of probably 301 is the way I'm uh the
I'm sorry the sheen amendment to 301 is
how I'm
thinking of it
if she if the sheen amendment is going
to be the basis to which the rewrite
occurs then then maybe that's how we
should
move forward then if that's
if that's going to be the framework
um
that sounds reasonable I I no I agree
with that other otherwise we're just
going to put all the ingredients of the
cake on the table individually in peace
yeah and which which is okay too it's
just if which is actually how
it's in my head
um visualizing it um but it what's in my
head
um right nobody else uh as is privy to
at this point but I would say just for
sake of argument
um
that if we take on the Xi'an Amendment
if we take lines
um
and
and insert in that language as neatly as
possible the
the
language from
insert the household definition yeah
into into that
um
yeah Romans 6 in on page 36 into that
uh
I don't know that it would belong there
it seems as though that would belong in
whatever part of
of um
I yes it could it would have to be at
least in both but some of the language
from that
where where it talks about when the
legislator or any person living in the
household with the legislator are
financially dependent on the legislator
that's that language needs to come from
Roman six I got you now I got you yeah
I just can't do the quick cut and paste
in my head
but everybody sees what I'm proposing
and
hasn't okay
yeah
um and then there would be somewhere
that
um the definition so so for for the
purpose of construction pretty much the
first page is all set
I think so until we get to the back I
think so as long now we still I haven't
heard any conflict or or objection to
the idea of having recusal be
um
when there is that conflict but still
having the verbal disclosure when we're
dealing with testimony and
um
testimony and debate
um which is
what's the number on that
I seem to have now two pages of this
disclosure being page two line three
um
page two line three right so there's the
verbally disclose
on the record for participating in
testimony in committee and debate on the
floor
when there is a conflict and and
when this conflict during any official
legislative activity blah blah blah so
recusal for voting but they can still
you need the microphone to speak so it's
speak right and that was in an effort as
I think I said earlier to make sure that
we still are able to represent our
constituents
but just not vote you still can Advocate
you still can do all of those same
things
I've got a puzzle look on the face of
the clerk again here
maybe from a practical standpoint this
may not be the the right time we can
come back to it but
um the exclusions to recusal and stuff
in committee and just pulling from my
experience on Commerce I'm not sure how
would I know
if there's going to be a problem with
quorum
uh I I think we were moving removing
that sentence Oh okay we haven't even
discussed that part of this yet we're
yeah
taking it line by line right pretty much
we'll we will
Mr chairman uh just just for clarity
um
it has always been the practice that and
and and
by operation that if you have declared
the conflict you don't participate
period that includes speaking on the
bill
um include voting and voting so if
you've declared a conflict you don't
participate period you don't speak you
don't
vote
so how yep how do you get go ahead I'll
our audience of two probably
one being my 99 year old mother
I think chairman I know chairman
Gordon's intention was yeah that the
only change is to be made
he humbly yes
would be to
do what's here
I guess along with the exclusion
uh
provision you mentioned and changes to
the effective date because this his
proposal would leave in place everything
else that's existed for the last 30
years including special interests though
including a whole other section of
needless words as far as I can see
true
but maybe his thought was just take
things one step incrementally because
changing the conflict of interest
definition opens up a whole can of worms
in terms of many other things
including in in the guidelines the
prohibited activity section which talks
all about
things you cannot do legislators cannot
do if they have a conflict of interest
that's one issue so so leaving the
conflict of interest
um and and tell tell us where that is
we got to get rid of these pages to find
initially on
page uh no 12 is the
see now we still actually in here still
have the verbal disclosure of conflicts
so we we have there's a difference
between verbal disclosure of a conflict
of interest versus
a recusal so we still elect we allow
when you fill out the form if you note
what your
what your interest is
but you don't feel it's an interest
enough where it would impact your the
legislation and I think this is what
what chairman Gordon was speaking to
generally regarding the cola adjustment
you know if if a hundred members had
filed the form saying that we're going
to get this however not any more than
anybody else then that's acceptable uh
because there is they can still
participate but when you fill out this
declaration of intent saying I will not
participate that means the whole thing
the whole gamut so that means when
you're in committee you're not even
gonna you're not even gonna
participate at all but for example
representative Sanborn for example is a
business owner and as an operator of a
casino when she testifies in front of
Commerce or Ways and Means about those
issues she verbally discloses her
interests in that but she does not
declare a conflict in the in the sense
that she's not going to participate
I understand and and
um
personally that's the part I have a
problem with
um I um I think there are things that
um verbally just and I believe that
that's what the Ethics Committee is
saying verb there are circumstances
where verbal disclosure does not absolve
you of your ability to
do things
um of a
official Duty capacity and and that's
why specifically when we were doing 301
we
delineated
um
the the effort to be able to represent
your constituents and and test and
testify and debate
but not vote and and made that
distinction
because in that
um
opinion that I received
I was told at that point that I could
not do anything I could not talk with
even other fellow legislators in the
hall about that subject matter
um so it to me that at that point I was
not able to represent my constituents
and I chose
the different paths than than what I had
asked for so
it was important to me to represent my
constituents and
I thought that the way we drafted this
to us still allow the the individual
legislator to participate in everything
except that vote was the best way of
being able to satisfy my constituents
and my need to not
well
so so to that point Mr chairman I think
that it that's going to require
um because just as as for practical
purposes we all know our level of
Precedence in the New Hampshire house so
it's the Constitution House Rules custom
usage and precedent Mason's manual and
then statute and because our rules and
and our customs Trump statute we're
going to need to change rules as well to
accomplish what you're which is why I
fully agree that what we need to do here
is change that effective date to a time
when we've already we're when we're
re-establishing rules I would think
um
I don't know what does everyone think
about the idea of
um of separating the idea rather than
just have a complete
divorce of your ability to act as a
legislator
um instead you would have the ability to
um debate and and testify
um but not vote yep
testify yes
because if you if you recuse
and you're out of everything according
to the way it's written now basically
um
you still have the right
as an individual
which is all you have as a as an uh
legislator anyway
to testify
but you could not then
take part in the back and forth unless a
question was directed like right now
directing it to the clerk or something
like that
uh once you were done and there were no
questions you'd go sit out there and you
wouldn't be part of anything any longer
how about yourself
debating on the floor no because you
have recused yourself
you do not have an individual's right
your mother 99 can't come in and debate
on the phone oh yes she can
um so but the question for me then is
are you fully
benefiting
those that voted you into office yes
because you're giving the same thing
from that seat
that you would espouse from one of the
microphones up here
you just get to do it once versus two
three four five six seven times however
long it takes
as a
as a citizen legislature which is what
we seem to pride ourselves on
well-knowledged in certain areas
and
I can see a problem I can see a problem
where those people are needed
under what circumstance are you talking
about not being able the current system
well the current situation to me seems
to work okay
well so that's complete if you have a
conflict of interest you are
complete so you
so you're you're looking at changing the
definition of conflict of interest and
one of the things that is not worded
anywhere in here is a is a precedent
that we've established
and that is to add would be affected
differently from other members of the
class to which the legislator belongs
that to me is a deal breaker in this
entire endeavor
because we have circumstances that are
holistic that in the case I'll use her
vet tech example
where it applies to an industry versus
this particular benefit of say the
hospital merger example
if we start taking away the ability to
discuss things that that affect things
globally
we're doing a disservice to this
legislature because in a lot of cases
folks that happen to be extraordinarily
knowledgeable in certain areas happen to
be the ones that file legislation in
those areas
or that's why or they get someone else
to do it but that's precisely why I am
asking for their knowledge
I'm just not giving it in the in these
these bills that's pers that the citizen
legislature is exactly where I am
I'm saying however
uh for all of those reasons in the
findings here I think it's very
important that we get their information
which is why I'm I'm opening up their
ability to verbally debate and testify
and
um and suck that knowledge out of their
head
I'm only saying that if you are
benefiting
from the vote then that's that I think
is how where the definition where where
our current situation falls apart I
don't I don't buy the idea that because
someone else is getting a vote getting a
benefit you aren't it's it's how it
affects you is the most important part
you're the one with the vote
um I don't care whether yeah but Jones
is getting sure and that would be true
for an individual a very specific
benefit that you would receive due to
the circumstances of that but if we
start shutting everything down from a
global standpoint every realtor that has
ever served in this house can just wave
goodbye because they'll never be able to
come back
so no yeah that's exactly it because
especially in the case of Realtors
there's I mean my first term here for
some reason we just had a ton of real
estate bills
and
but the arguments that I heard as a
freshman rep was these are globally
affected things they're not affecting
certain realty companies or certain
areas it's a it's an industry Global
thing so so each one of those wouldn't
except that but we're looking to change
the definition here that's going to get
rid of that it's hard to use it in a
vacuum I I think
I think you'd have to see each one of
those individual bills and and whether
it affected again we're we're dealing
with 400 individuals with 400
circumstances and it's awfully hard to
say
um what each one should do which is why
I think it's important that we give
guidelines to the legislators so that
they can make the decision for
themselves I agree with the concept of
having guidelines but when we're talking
about changing definitions of conflict
of interest and other things that is
what the committee uses to make
decisions based on why you're in front
of the Ethics Committee
so that those are two irrespective
things a guideline is to help a
legislator make a determination as to
what they should personally do in
changing what's in this book are
irrespective of each other they are two
different things
and that's that's getting the loss we
were talking about that the ethics has
my goal is to not ever visit the Ethics
Committee quite frankly
um that that's what I think we should
all have as a goal
um
or to be able to answer
our actions for the Ethics Committee
this is why I talk about the Safe Harbor
that gives the ability for the
legislator to say gee if this is a real
what's the word the other word they use
apparent a real or a parent financial
interest
that's what keeps you out of
visiting our friends in the Ethics
Committee
um
but I don't want to lose our ability to
gain knowledge from people that have
specific knowledge in an area I think
there there's definitely some there's
definitely some areas that we that we
can agree on here to deal with the lay
issue if we'll call it that
but I think going past that right now is
just we're biting off too much at once
okay we're biting off too much at once
so fair point I might I might have
gotten a little bit lost but but it
helped me out um and I want to pull
towards Lori and I know she wouldn't
mind uh I I had a worked with Lori
Sanborn a lot on Commerce
um and in Commerce in general in
subcommittees in work sessions and in
executive sessions there were times
where we would verbally disclose all
this like at any time there was uh I
used to live in a trailer park
so anytime there was any Bill relating
to that I would also by the way I live
in trailer park but I'm participating
you know what I mean uh Lori and a few
others on the committee would have to
verbally say I'm a business owner I mean
15 times in a day at least so are you
saying that we're gonna take
the she can verbally she can either
Advocate and participate and and but not
be able to vote at all
and if is is that what we're so we're
taking page 13 we're taking that section
seven verbal disclosure of where we just
sort of announced verbally that you know
Lori's Laurie owns a business but but
she's going to participate in the in the
committee work I think if Laurie my
understanding I've never served on
Commerce so I I I'm somewhat hampered by
the issues that she's talking about when
she verbally discloses my understanding
is Laurie
hers on the side that I'm talking that
that she verbally discloses
um all the time because we can still
participate in the vote
oh I'm sorry because we can still
participate in the vote I'm saying all
right are you saying if there's uh um
any if there is a conflict I'm saying
that
um that would cause
a trigger of this conflict of interest
definition that we have whether it's the
existing one or not I'm saying that
there should be two Avenues to take to
either
disclose and participate
at the testimony table land or in
executive session but not vote
yeah you're gonna
um You're Gonna Lose quorum
you're going to lose Quorum if that's
the case and and that's and that well
but right now if she has that quote if
she has that conflict
we're hearing from our clerk that that
it's for everything and that apparently
doesn't take place Mr chairman if I
could I'd like to just read house rule
106 to you
um it says uh the approval of a majority
of the Quorum president shall be
required for a committee to decide a
question or to take official action on
any matter provided however that a
member who has filed a declaration of
intent pursuant to the ethics guidelines
that the member will not participate
shall not be required to vote and shall
not be counted for the purposes of
determining the number necessary for
establishing important to act on that
question so in that case
um you know if if you have 20 people
present your Quorum just drops by one so
19 so you need 10 for a majority
position
and I noticed that length that same
language in a number of states when we
were looking at
um what they do they didn't determine
um for purposes of Quorum whether there
was a conflict so that that takes care
of the Corn part so if we lose five the
Quorum drops right if we lose five yeah
yes but if we get to a point where you
have less than an actual Quorum you have
a 20-person committee and and 10 people
are not able to participate yeah I'm
concerned so the the only thing with
that was the reason why that should
excuse me yeah that should happen now if
if we're following
the rule of everything but I think Mr
chairman that
it's filing their conflicts and not
participating and there's a again I go
back to this difference between not
participating versus disclosing
um and still participate you know
because there's nothing that prevents a
member from participating as long as
they're disclosing like I mentioned
Judge Lynn the other day he he drafted
the cacr for the purpose of benefiting
the brand the judicial branch
even though he's no longer a member of
that branch and this wouldn't affect him
he disclosed that he didn't have to but
he did and I think that that is
important for the discussion I would
also not for nothing just sort of
mention that there are 400 of you there
are very very very very few members who
are from single member districts
and you having disclosed that you have a
financial interest and are not
participating on a bill doesn't mean
that your constituents aren't
necessarily represented good point
there's just throwing that out there for
um does that help
it helps on the corn part can I also
just mention though
just from the the Strategic standpoint
of rules
you you can't bind one legislature to
the next so even if you all pass
legislation that says you're going to do
this and change the way that that our
operations internally work it still is
up inherent on the next legislature to
make that adjustment to their rules and
if they don't then the statute and the
rules don't Jive and we have other
issues to worry about
which is somewhat the point with our
other bill that
yes of course I cannot Advocate on any
sort of policy issue I'm just trying to
explain what I know is Chairman Gordon's
intent with this piece which was said
narrow
the times when members would be required
three skews
members could still voluntarily choose
to recuse
and members could also except for in
these two circumstances described in
paragraph one and two
they could still in almost every case
except for a few circumstances like
these
I.E the Doug lay situation and frm
they could still choose to disclose and
participate
all that would stay in place all the
definitions would stay in place it's
just that
in these circumstances you'd be required
to be cues is it is it possible to get
that special interest part out of this
sure
you could go back to
it was before the study Commission 2014.
and you could just have eliminate it and
just Define financial interest in
that may be the easiest solution out of
this
because it does open a can of worms
to
change the definition of conflict of
interest in terms of all the other
provisions
I I get the feeling however
um because I've seen it in the past and
we saw it from the original bill that
simply
adding new words
isn't getting us any closer to the idea
that was originally espoused we still
shortness or or understanding of what's
in this bill uh in this booklet it's
sure it's merely almost a Band-Aid
rather than a solution but that could be
achieved through these decision tree
Concepts and more
education with continuing education
sessions
and maybe some other publication this
this booklet
I don't know what could come out of this
it seems like there should be one
booklet that has everything that relates
to the ethics Provisions in it
but maybe there should be another entity
that would be
informal and shorter
um sort of like the decision decision
tree that was mentioned
because I don't know what would come out
of this there are two statutes which
affect ethics
and then there's the guidelines and then
there are the procedural rules I suppose
could come out of this but members have
um this is kind of a wild suggestion I'm
not sure how even I feel about it but um
I know great introduction
um if we're really concerned about the
conflict between our house rules and the
law would it just make more sense to get
rid of
the statute
so we don't have all these weird
definitions they just wouldn't exist
anymore
and then we would just do it all through
rules if I can
do are you intending to say that um we
just follow the house rules then correct
yes
yep
um chair for the clerk if I may
um and you say house rules it does take
precedent over the statute in this case
our house rules guide our actions in in
our procedures
um it is it is it is a higher order for
for what we follow
um
listen I I mean the fact of the matter
is the the ethics statute gives the um
was intended for you know sort of uh I
don't want to use the word tribunal but
a a
non-branch specific
um group to to weigh in and make
recommendations
um that being said
you know there if there are
if there are conflicts between the
statute and the rules of the two bodies
then you know the the rules Trump I
would I would note too that the it is a
requirement that when a new one of these
gets published that it has to be adopted
by both bodies
um
before before it is inactive
well but there are this is off topic but
there are things in here that we're not
adopted by both sure and in houses and
and correct and and I I would I would
note that that uh
I don't
in 1819 uh in 2019 we celebrated the
200th anniversary of the state s and I
produced a document for all the members
um and it was the 1819 rules and the
2019 rules and the 1819 rules were five
pages long and the 2019 rules were 27
pages
so I mean things have changed a lot in
200 years uh to get into uh to add a
whole segment of rules
um regarding disclosure and that sort of
thing if if that's up to I mean that
that would certainly be up to the body
to do all right but you know having
having the statute that that we look to
and and has been through both bodies is
certainly
up to you
comments anyone
yes
I think the
um
leaves a lot of open-ended uh
interpretation by
um in the sheen Amendment it says
matters on the merits free I'm on uh HB
301 Amendment
um line nine
matters on page one uh the first page
matters on the matters on the merits
free from conflicts of interest in both
real and apparent proper improper
influences but then you have the
um Allison's Amendment
on line five real or perceived Financial
or otherwise I think the definitions
need to be really tightened up because
perceived by whom well it needs to be
really tightened up of like is it a
constituent is it an activist group is
it another legislator that needs to be
really finitely defined of
who's making the complaint in on what
basis
um and the language is going to be
really important to Define when can an
Ethics complaint be brought forward on
what basis and anytime I know that but
it will it will
minimize the pool of people
that could if the language is really
tight and buttoned up on perceived is
anything I'm driving two miles over the
speed limit and they're gonna you know
point that out but it's perceived it's
not finitely defined well the Ethics
Committee did mention that as well
but the fact remains that it it does
exist in our
um this that that comes directly from
those findings came from the original
bill that we hung on to
to study last summer so
um
you can find
discrepancy or a dispute with the the
findings but
um
oh and I I don't disagree with that yeah
that has drawn from the existing
guidelines principles of Public Service
which has been in existence for the life
of the committee
and it's findings I don't know
that's very different
statement of findings than the actual
body
well if we're looking to do some
amendments this is so we're changing
something that's what the word Amendment
means so that this is where I'm going
with this if we're amending something
you don't want to amend it to make it
worse
well you want to make it you know
something that's a lot more just really
defined that's why we're amending
something because maybe there was some
gray area before so we're gonna really
you know dial it in at this point
um just so here's we have a we have a 10
minute deadline here um as far as I'm
concerned I have to be out of here at
noon but
um I guess I would like to hear
um how we handle this bill
and and I think this the options are
um is there is there interest in
in
um
putting something forth in any of the
fashions that we have in front of us
either either the Gordon Amendment the
Xi'an Amendment the existing 301
um and or is there interest in
retaining and playing with this over the
summer
is there or is there interest in
um any other options that anyone else
it's just my opinion but um that's all
we have it's a representative I would
rather move slower and get get it right
and be a hundred percent comfortable
then be a little bit hesitant and right
now I'm a little bit hesitant I like the
idea of what some of the things that
we're talking about I'm just on if you
ask me any piece any one of these I
think it all needs work to to button up
um so you know at this point I would say
I figured be better to retain than to
put something that
um
can get you know a lot of holes punched
into it or uh has the unintended
consequence of being more confusing than
not
the Gordon amendment was what was
suggested from the Ethics Committee no
correct okay no um he was very careful
in saying that this was not anything
that he had discussed with the Ethics
Committee except in an informal basis it
but he is also chair of the Ethics
Committee so
and then when we had met previously in a
previous session
um
I thought we had said or it had been
said that when we met again we would
have more insight from the meeting that
yeah we did say that yeah what was that
inside we'd have none oh okay a little
bit we did a little bit
they did they did make one statement and
that was
to go slow
in little changes
that's what I took from that from that
because there was a lot of disagreement
within there that was one of them of
many things so and I think that's good
advice okay
any any other
as someone that sits on the Ethics
Committee that
to keep moving forward but I'm looking
at the clock yes I understand
I'd like to retain and work on it over
the summer and then bring it back in the
fall
we had I I will point out
we had this opportunity Last Summer
how many yeah both of us showed up right
um
and uh and so
um I would only
I would only suggest that uh that not
happen again
this is something that is important and
it is important to do it correctly yeah
representative Richard
since it's also at the Ethics Committee
is that a way to if it is retained by
this committee
would the Ethics Committee be also
retaining it and working
day so how do
the two ever come together
to do the work
um not to my knowledge I don't think
we've ever uh ethic well you can better
answer but it would seem to me that I
apologize for my naive no no no no no
it's a fair question it Mr chairman they
operate independently yes sir where I'll
representative Richard's coming from uh
the Ethics Committee has outside members
and it's hard enough for us to schedule
a regular meeting let alone try to get
them to come into work during the summer
so I think that would be very difficult
to do
yep
we good
Jeff just yeah sure sure so if
there was to be work done
to make it better
and hard work
done
that would have to happen within us
retaining it here
yes is that what that is fair to say
fair to say it is if we were to retain
it we would be retaining it with the
expectation that that work would be done
here by more than two people showing up
in the summer
um well yes yes
Mr chairman so yes next week is the
reporting deadline but your today's your
scheduled session day right
um retaining means that it's held in
this committee for action and it does
give the committee chair a time to
schedule meetings and for the record
these would be work sessions and you
could have full committee work sessions
you have you could have subcommittee
work sessions and you can invite any
member of Ethics to participate uh
certainly representative wall being a
member of Ethics is you know well poised
to do that chairman Lynn of Judiciary is
the other uh appointee from the house
he's he could certainly be invited to
participate
um there are opportunities and then
later this fall
um there would be the deadline to act by
the full committee to recommend to the
Full House and then we would take up
that legislation in January
um
see
yeah and I I think we're so close too
that's why I don't want to rush and vote
on this because I think we're a lot
farther than we were last year this
summer and I think we're so close of
getting it
um to a point where I think it can be
smarter people so you know why not take
the summer and get a really good bill in
agreed
see work sessions are sometimes
beneficial
um
with that unless there's any other
comment um we'll be back at one o'clock
for exact Session 1 30 sorry
um
and um and I'll close the work session
the other the other part of the work
session
um
I think we will be talking about uh we
had we had set aside for HB 157 as well
um if if Mr Lambert can be back at uh 1
30 and we'll we'll do that
if you would prefer we can do that right
at the beginning of it
Mr chairman I think
my my hope is Chairman Gordon did ask me
to convey on that that there is
consensus on the Ethics Committee which
is that they
do not want to take a position policy
wise on House Bill 157 in terms of
whether the committee should have
jurisdiction over the policy of
harassment
that's an issue that they feel that
should be made elsewhere okay in terms
of leadership and
that would be interesting
um
okay so that will take up 157 as part of
the executive session
um if if it's difficult
that that would mean that um
I don't think we would need you then for
the exact session if that I don't want
to take up your entire day
but if you are here at 1 30 you will be
welcome and if you are here we will take
up 157 first if that helps you at all
301 we will take up as well
one after another
okay
great um thanks everybody uh I'll
adjourn the work session on
now we're back
um
thanks everybody everybody for
substituting for us we appreciate your
your assistance
um I'm looking for a motion on
cacr3
related to recall elections
oh that's me oh God the first one
already and uh motion to itl and I will
suck on that
okay
um moved by
um would either of you like to speak to
representative Hobson would you like to
speak to your motion sure uh here in New
Hampshire we have a
very responsive uh elect election
process I did not prepare anything as
you can tell we have a very responsive
election process and uh
uh the turnover is is quite great the
voters are very uh knowledgeable and it
really is an incumbent upon them to vet
out their candidates properly I think if
if we were to have recalls every time
someone's unhappy we would spend all of
our time in the election mode so for
that reason I think we should itl
we had testimony that this is enabling
legislation it is enabling but for what
purpose uh by the time we would form any
kind of committee that could handle this
it would take time and then the process
would have to be developed and we'd have
to go through it we've had a bill like
this many times before and every time it
has been killed mainly because of what
representative Hobson said we have an
election every two years
and this kind of process could take far
more than two years so there's a process
we have for the general public deciding
whether or not they want to keep someone
in the office and it works so if it's
not broken don't fix it thank you
I will say a couple of things one is
we've had this bill at least
13. this might be the 14th time that it
um as our as just 2018 if I total up the
uh the yeas and nays uh
35 45 to nothing is the total just in
committee on on this bill
um it is
truly one of those bills that we we've
been told that we have to pass it to
find out what's in it
um which should give us all pause
especially when we're dealing with
something as important as changing our
constitution
the sponsor nor anyone else that
testified gave us any idea of what's
behind the curtain we have no idea what
the cost would be or who is responsible
for them we have no idea what elected
officials would be included we have no
idea how long the process would take to
determine if it's even feasible from a
practical standpoint of how long in that
process we would be
um the one thing that I also would like
to point out is if you read the bill and
and the language that's on page two that
goes from line six to line 33 would be
the wording of the question that's put
to the qualified voter
um
I counted it out 404 words
um would have to be read by the person
in the in the voting booth
um and the question would just be are
you in favor of amending article
five of the second part of the
they would have to find this is like one
of those
um cartoon games or or
travel games where you have two pictures
and you have to determine which one is
the is what changed in those two
pictures except they only give you one
picture and you have to try to figure
out what's the thing that changes
um and it turns out it's 22 words out of
those 40 404 words that change and it's
right in the middle so you have to
question whether someone would actually
read all 404 words to determine whether
those 22 are different and whether they
agree with them or not
so
um
and then you'd have to convince 60
percent of the population to vote in
your in your favor I think it's unlikely
that this would pass and I think there's
a reason why this has been before us 14
times and failed oh 14 times
so with that
um
as my backdrop I if there's no other
questions I will or discussion I will
thank you okay uh Vanessa Shan yes rep
Shane
rep Stephen Boyd yes
rep costable yes
rep Hobbs in the clerk votes yes rep
Pearson yes
rep McCarter yeah
yeah reptierney
no
Richards yes
rep Seibert yes
rep Perez
yes
rep Montiel Montel sorry
nope not here it's not here
did I say it right Monte is it Montiel
not here
not me oh I'm sorry when people do that
to the clerk I'm like what is wrong with
14-1 the motion passes
the power of 14-1
um the bill is IPL
um I would move consent
and sent without objection
consent it is where does that go on here
do I put consent anywhere
all right there's a reason okay um will
there be a Minority Report
all reports will be uh puts on the
consent calendar why would he write a
thank you
fine yep you're right okay he doesn't
need to be a report though
on the consent calendar no there needs
to be a description
I'm sorry is it not consented no it I it
is consent there was no minority right
right
I I messed up all right
thank you
um
all right so
with no Minority Report on consent 14 to
nothing I'll close the 14-1 I'll close
one second to reset
okay
in
internet I said it does
it okay yeah sorry about buying where
the consent goes on there no
no
consent okay
so does anyone need a report
for this
I mean it has to there has to be a
description
do you want me to okay yeah I'm happy to
okay
all right we're back
um cacr4 uh relating to compensation for
legislators providing that legislators
biannual biennial salary compensation be
increased
do I have a motion you do
um
on cacr4 I'm sorry itl on cacr4
representative
would you like to speak qmotion yes sir
cacr4 covered the annual salary
increase of the legislature
in testimony we heard that
the last time this was done was in 1889
there was lengthy discussion as to what
other states do
and also what the realization of the
implementation of this particular piece
of
legislation would mean
no biennium my my bad
one of the things that
New Hampshire seems to Pride itself on
and I suppose I do in a ways is the fact
that we are a citizen legislature this
particular legislation would not make us
a professional legislature
but it would make us not a citizen
legislator legislature either it kind of
put us in kind of a
a place in the middle I suppose
so
with that being said and with the
long-standing tradition of us operating
the way that we do that
that would seem to lend itself to the
ital motion
foreign thank you
um
forgetting that
port itl and my reason for doing this is
because even though we've had this
before a number of times and sometimes
it takes a number of times to get
something passed this hasn't improved
there are legislators who are legitimate
and wanting to be paid more and I truly
respect that I wouldn't mind being paid
more that's for sure
but the point is I don't think we should
be changing the Constitution at this
time the Constitution's a sacred
document in all the years that I worked
in judiciary we treated it as a sacred
document you don't change it unless
there's a real public need and reason
for it we have members of the
legislature who do want to change it
this isn't going to if it gets through
the committee it won't get through the
house and if it does get through the
house it definitely won't go through the
Senate
um yes folk maybe a feel-good type of
vote and I respect that but at the same
time
we're not going to get the general
public to support us in wanting this the
general public knows where our volunteer
legislators and that we do this out of
our own Good Will and yes it would be
nice as I said to have more money
but the cost to the state would be
prohibitive from what I'm told and how
do you pay legislators when we have a
committee that doesn't have a lot of
bills and we're not here very much how
do you pay a committee like when I was
on Judiciary and you have 73 bills
and they're here so much more than we
are how do you make that fair
because if you pay just say forty
thousand dollars or even ten thousand
dollars
they're going to say to us you're
getting an awful lot of money compared
to the work we're doing that's not right
so how do you differentiate between
who's here for legitimate reasons a
whole lot longer than other people are
here you can't do it it doesn't work
that way
um it would be really really complex to
do it if we're going to change how we're
paid we should start with a real study
committee find out what our real needs
are what is a reasonable salary and then
you're going to have to look at the size
of the legislature how many people are
we going to be paying
and we have had bills before for
diminishing the size of the legislature
so we could increase pay but that has
never gone into any serious study before
we're not I don't believe you start at
the top and say we want this and then
figure out later on what you're going to
do about it you first figure out what
you're going to do
and then when you have substantial
evidence go for it so I can't support
thank you representative wall any
further discussion represent payer
hi I'm just going to speak against the
itl
um because
I like this bill because it was brought
forward by bipartisan
legislators and
in my opinion it's a matter of matter of
practicality I don't believe that in
1889 the legislatures who voted for that
200 they created that number based on
that time the value in this bill is
adjusted for inflation it's practical
and even though yes we are volunteers so
are Selectmen so our school board
members so Arc sewer Commissioners and
whatnot through all our municipalities
and they get a stipend that is almost
similar to what this would be per year
so I think that it's practical I think
it's reasonable and I think that a lot
of folks could use that it to help them
to free class to do this job because it
really is a job and
um folks that live up in the north
country that need to come down for
multiple committee days you know could
help us
offset the cost of staying in a hotel
it's just practicality for
um this job because it is a job and I
think that having a stipend is
appropriate given that all other elected
positions in the state down to a school
board member get a stipend two thousand
three thousand per year Etc so
um even executive counselors get a
salary of 16 000 or something like that
so I don't think it's absurd and so that
is I'm going against the itl
representative Tierney
Mr correct a few items from the
microphone
I just thought I did
I'm from the North country
our school board members
nine hundred dollars a year
our Board of Selectmen twenty four
hundred dollars a year
there we are in session as the board of
Selectmen and I'm one
uh far more often than down here
and it is far less money but it is still
done
for uh as a basically as a volunteer and
that 2400
four years ago was only twelve hundred
dollars
so we've gotten a small raise up there
uh I am in favor of itl on this one
as a matter of principle
no legislature should ever be allowed to
give itself a raise
none
if we if we end up getting paid more
sometime someday down around whenever
it's going to change the character of
the legislature we won't be volunteers
anymore it's going to cost a lot more to
get elected because more people will be
wanting the job because it's easier to
be here actually to get paid and I'm not
saying they're doing it for the money
Nobody Does it for that we do it because
we love what we're doing as volunteers
for citizens of New Hampshire
but every testimony I've heard over the
years on this particular bill has been
it will change the character of this
legislature many people will not be
coming
because they can't afford to run for
election unless they've got big
donations coming from somewhere else
so it will be a different character
altogether I don't know what the law
making will be then but it'll be more
professional perhaps than it is now I
will say that as legislators and as
volunteers we can deduct our expenses on
our taxes that helps offset some things
but at the same time yeah and why don't
you tell me now I tell you yeah I I just
you know as a matter of principle I know
you all want those of you who want the
bill wants it and I respect that but I
again I just can't do it because I just
don't believe this is the right vehicle
to use we won't change the Constitution
at this time if anything study this
figure out what you want figure out what
the size of the legislature will be
figure out how you're going to pay
people differently at different levels
and then go from there and I was
actually looking up something for labor
law last week and I was realizing that
this may not only affect what happens to
New Hampshire but labor law May have to
come into this from the federal
government it's a complex issue thank
you
thank you representative wall any other
further discussion representative yes I
was just kind of wondering
what would it deal with if you try to go
for per diem
so if you show up here you get a per
um
excellent question uh not covered by
I'm assuming you didn't want an answer
you were just a rhetorical question
right yeah
uh representative Perez that I'm allowed
to like give my opinion on it if you
have one you can give it okay so I I
will
I'm gonna speak against the ideal motion
I would love to see more
younger generation running for office I
would love to pass
my baton you know when I'm ready to not
be I'm not saying you know I'm getting
I'm not 80 but but I would love to see a
new generation
coming in and replace some of us here
and I believe giving it two hundred
dollars when we ask in new generations
to run for office
um is something that I don't think many
of them can do especially if they're
planning to have a family
I you know I want to see new generation
new ideas come in here but I don't want
to take away you know their right to to
have a family to you know to have a
house or or build something for the
future and two hundred dollars it
doesn't cut up trust me I you know it's
hard for someone who wants to be a
legislator
and then has to work 52 hours a week and
that's what I need to do in order for me
to stay be a stair rep I have to work 52
hours a week
and then that has to be a legislator I'm
not complaining but it's hard you know
I'm grateful that you know my kids are
30 and 27 but I'm just picture you know
uh younger generation where you know
they want to start building a family
that doesn't cut off you know and and
the time that we spending here in plus
52 hours or 40 hours a full-time job
words that live in us you know I'm I'm
just saying you know I'm not I'm not
saying you know everyone needs to get
paid but for the ones that needs to get
paid you know I wish you know we can
like
think about how we can move this forward
you know without
compromise you know without taking away
from the taxpayers but you know again
you know
I would like to see more opportunities
thank you representative Perez
representative Carter
hi I'd like to respond to representative
Perez I live paycheck to paycheck I work
60 hours a week I work nights after I
leave here I go and work nights so I can
do this
that was an accommodation my employer
afforded me so I could do this I didn't
used to do that I used to worked a
regular day
um
and I knew what I was signing up for for
the 200 for two years I knew that there
are uh legislators in here that are very
young Valerie McDonald she's 18. so
somehow she is making it work I don't
know how it's not my business really
there's a way if there's a will as a way
and I'm making it work
sacrificing home life sacrificing
payroll sacrificing nights and not
sleeping and coming here right after
getting out of work there's a way to do
it if you're really
uh vested in doing this there is a way
and I don't think the monetary aspect is
the reason to do it I think it's your
love of state or County or town or
country whatever it is
um I think it's uh the volunteer aspect
of this is what should drive people not
the financial
um
you know reward that's what I think our
state was created on it this was a
volunteer project for people to do and
that's why I signed up to do it and I
also didn't know that I was also
volunteering to be my County delegation
which really sucks
um I hate it so much but I have to do it
that is what I signed up for so I don't
even think throwing twenty thousand
dollars a year at it would make me want
to do that I have to do it though that's
what I signed up for so I appreciate
thank you for your colorful remarks I
yes absolutely just um being a woman in
here
um no events um I think we're all equal
but then at the same token when this was
first like thought of with the 200 you
know we were given the speech during
orientation about
you know how we're supposed to dress or
expected to dress that type of thing you
know clothing like that costs money if I
was a male I could buy like three suits
and be like cool you know and some ties
but
you know you know with women if you buy
a dress you gotta have the bra and
everything to go with it and I think all
y'all if y'all are married or anything
like that have been through this I'm
getting ready to go out to dinner or
anything so there's like these little
things and you know I think you know two
to six thousand dollars isn't
necessarily gonna be like yes let me go
do this because I'm gonna live off this
money you know
when it comes to like paying for housing
costs and the other things you need in
life so that's just my two cents on that
thank you thank you
anyone else
okay quick history
um and and uh
we've been provided some very good
committee's researcher going back to
2000 there's been about two thousand uh
two dozen bills that have been referred
to us on this bill
um I just did a quick math and it looks
like in total
it's been 65 votes to kill and 13 votes
in favor
um it's it's made it to the house twice
um as a not to pass both times it failed
um as ought to pass and then went to an
expedient to legislate
um been to re refer to interim study
once by and large it is come up those
two dozen times and it has failed those
two dozen times
um again not the reason to uh
to kill it again but maybe a good
indicator I should have mentioned in the
first uh couple of builds or the first
bill there is also the online
um
voting system
um or indicator where people have
emailed in the either
text
um their their testimony and or the
opposition or opposed on this particular
Bill there were 13 people opposed to it
and eight people in support of it and
there is some testimony here that will
make it into the record but I do
encourage everyone to uh to utilize that
system it is a great way to read some of
the testimony that others have sent in
by and large the testimony came in
one two three four five people opposed
and sent in testimony and one two three
sent in testimony in support of it
um
no other discussion I will ask the clerk
to call the roll
we are moving we are voting on itl on
cacr4
cacr4 motion to itl rep uh Sheen yes
rep Boyd yes
repcostable yes
the clerk votes yes
Brett Pearson yes
Brett McCarter
reptierney yes
rep wall yes
reptarcot no
rep Richards
yes
no
rep Perez
that Montiel is not here rep payer no
excuse me so we have 10
ten to five uh we are at itl on cacr4
[Music]
this time I'm I'm not going to put that
on consent obviously and I'm wondering
if there will be a Minority Report
yep
rep payer will do the Minority Report
um
tomorrow close the business
why
um send it to me do you have the the
electronic form
no
I will make sure there is a um there is
a form that you can use online
um
I'm not sure if I oh we may have hard
caught we actually probably do have we
should have part there you go so it's up
to you you can it would be
or attachment a Word document or
something
um would you like to follow the format
of what we have here well it would be
much easier for her if it comes in on an
electronic version for Jamie
um so it's up to you whichever you're
I can really do who's going to speak on
the floor of the house so I need to be
able to report that
um does anybody know for sure I don't I
don't
um I would assume Brett Pearson made the
motion I'm assuming that rep Pearson
would be comfortable speaking on the
um so rep Pearson speaking
is there any of the the four members
um voting nope five members voting that
would like to
be responsible
for speaking on the floor when is it
going to go on the floor don't know
okay you will you will we'll talk we'll
discuss it as we go
thank you
um so we have a Minority Report do we
have a majority report yes
representative oh okay all right
all right so we're closing the executive
session on cacr or
um
if you give him a minute to
do I need anything I don't know I'm good
moving right along
hb134 okay I will open the exact session
on
um HP
134 and recognize our representative
um that's good thank you is there a
second
Ed by representative constable
um
rep McCarter would you like to speak to
your motion sure I have to find it in my
phone sorry I didn't print it out this
morning
um
I sent that to you Vanessa yes
I think HP 134 is looking to create a
collective bargaining agreement with the
legislative staff
and my experience with working in the
unions
um
is that it's just
um the incentives to level the playing
field with regards to salaries and
benefits however the unintended
consequences of
um such a collective bargaining
agreement will eliminate the individual
negotiating power based on Merit and
performance which is important when we
all go to work we want to be recognized
by if we work hard we want to be
rewarded for that and the guy who's kind
of slacking off of the gal who's
slacking off we don't want to be the
same as them we want to shine above that
and typically a Union contract does not
permit that you're just you're all the
same
but it's based on seniority if you work
there a year more than the guy behind
you or the gal behind you you're able to
advance and
get that promotion regardless of your
performance and the person under you a
year or two under you in seniority isn't
eligible for that same advancement even
if they work harder and do a better job
seniority per doesn't permit that so
um just in my experience with a typical
Union negotiated contracts and that
seniority model model
um
I would say that this is probably a
Pandora's Box that we don't want to open
and nobody has asked for this this is
the union coming in
um looking for an open door and when
that door opens just an inch they'll
swing it wide open so I would
um seriously
recommend that the committee votes for
Ito
thank you rep Carter
um we seconded it I've got a rep
Constable would you like to speak to it
no well just real quick the
um as we heard in the testimony this
would affect I believe a total of 12
individuals that didn't ask for it
um they were never even asked their
opinion of it uh this was is just one of
these bills that was done on their
behalf for you know and without their
input at all and for that reason alone I
would say that um that's an inexpedient
thank you representative any other
further discussion
representative Perez
yeah the only reason that I'm supporting
the itl is because
I was told that you know they did the
the people who's going to be affected by
this bill wasn't even involved in the
conversation but to be honest uh
I'm one of those people who is being
part of the Union Nam Union
and I have a lot of respect for the
union I
don't agree with you know that unions uh
are bad or juniors are like take
seniority and they don't see your
potential they do and they give you
opportunities on your potential as well
um I do have respect for the unions but
you know like I say you know the only
reason that I'm I'm supporting the ideal
on this one is because the people who is
involved on this um didn't even be part
of the conversation that make me feel
uncomfortable about trying to unionize
someone who doesn't even know that uh
than being Universe you know that's the
thank you represent Perez rip wall
be
um there are 24 house staff employees
here they've never been surveyed as you
know and they seem to be very content
with their jobs some of these people are
my dear friends and I have asked them if
they want to be unionized and they don't
these people have been here a long time
and the speaker relies on institutional
knowledge when it comes time to working
with the house our schedules and what
where the bills are assigned and this
that and the other and as well as for
all the people we have who are the
lawyers who write up our bills because
these people have been here a long time
they're content and happy and not having
a union I I just can't support a union
especially as I said because they've
never been surveyed thank you
thank you representative wall any
further discussion representative Turka
well I guess here we go because I
probably should be accused myself still
I think you're fine
um
before
it's a good thought though thank you
thanks for testing the system for us
um
the um
any further discussion represent Perez
yeah I do have a question I'm not
working through a union right now but
I'm a union member so I wonder if I have
to
you would have to be an active member of
SEIU 1984 for this to be a conflict of
interest okay
okay good
everybody's happy
um I was born I would like to
add in a couple of quick comments one is
again we've had this bill a number of
times the comments are particularly
interesting from some of the committee
reports
um our own speaker Sharon Packard um
wrote the blurb for for one of these and
it says the bill is flawed in it that it
would take away the authority of the
presiding officers to deal directly with
hiring and firing and instead place in
the hands of the respective subcommittee
of the joint committee on legislative
facilities
the bill has unintended consequences the
legislative branch is a political body
and the leadership of both Chambers both
parties must have the option of having
the people around them that they need in
order to be effective
that was interesting also this one that
said there is much confusion caused
around the Bill's language for example
the office of legislative Services could
be representing represented by one Union
while the speaker's office could be
represented by another clerk's office
still another contrary to what we heard
um no I'm not going that far
um and that's uh
that seems to be the case for all of the
other reasons that we heard
um I think it's a good thing to itl the
online testimony submissions were three
to three three support three opposed
there were
two items that were typed testimony one
with that I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll we are dealing with itl on House
Bill 134.
void yes
repcoastable yes
yeah Quirk votes yes rep Pearson yes
Webb McCarter yeah
yeah reptierney yes rep wall yes
rep nodding Wong yes
rep Richards
okay 14. and the clerk that's the chair
yes I need more caffeine don't worry
folks every single committee does this
not just this one I swore I would be
different
we are at uh
we are at 15-20
rep Ricardo you will provide us a
and I think I'll close the hearing uh
the exact session on House Bill 134
and give a minute to reset and we'll be
okay I'm gonna open the executive
session on House Bill 157 recognize
myself
um as uh and I would offer
seconded by representative wall
representative wall would you like to
please turn your mic on
remember that I'm sorry
um it's a complex issue as to who will
have the jurisdiction over sexual
harassment cases
um you know if there's real sexual
harassment occurring we need to act on
and act on it quickly we can't just let
things ride if this goes before uh the
Ethics Committee there's a process that
has to be followed and it takes time we
do have a section of our guidelines if
you look at your purple book you'll see
that we do have such a section that does
refer to sexual harassment but not to
the level that we're talking about here
um I we need to decide who's going to
have jurisdiction
over these kinds of cases it's something
that's come to the Forefront in recent
years and I think we need to take time
to it effectively and do it
right thank you
thank you representative wall any
I have one or two things that I would
like to say one is the the online
testimony offered 38 people opposed to
the bill
and four in support I would uh with no
written testimony I would
um point you to page 58 of the uh the
purple book as it was colloquially
referred to
um and I would point out also that all
of this was approved February 4th 2020
by The Joint legislative facilities
committee
um
not everything that at this point is I'm
aware everything that the Ethics
Committee is responsible for
or or deals in their wheelhouse has to
be approved by both bodies of the house
this was not but
it was cleverly drafted and asked that
the information from here would be put
inside the ethics booklet so it's kind
of a conundrum just in that and in a in
and of itself so
um they're they're there are a number of
issues that need to be handled
um it was probably a mistake on my part
to make it a work session for
um and basically an hour
we need more time to deal with putting
this in the right order again with the
good intention of trying to make this
booklet actually be helpful
I'm not sure it is so with that
um I will if there's no further
discussion I will ask the clerk to call
oh
all right so this is to retain Bill 157
uh rep she and yes
rep Boyd yes
repcoastable yes
yes the clerk votes yes rep Pearson yes
rep MC Carter yeah
reptierney yes rep wall yes
rep nutting Wong yes wrapped terracott
rep Richards yeah
rep Seibert yes
rep Perez yes
until's not here red pair
and the chair yes
okay so 15-0 retain any objection to
consent
oh doesn't go on consent never mind
all right
um close the exact section on House Bill
157 moving to House Bill 245 and I would
recognize rep Pearson for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move itl on House Bill
245.
rep Pearson would you like to speak to
your motion thank you Mr chair
so
I had the pleasure of serving
with
the name that just completely vanished
my brain
Marple representative Marple I did my
freshman term representative Marple was
still in the house
uh and I listened to his
his discussion of this uh uh you know
from his own mouth he's been quoted a
lot but I I heard it directly from him
the the situation though that surrounds
this bill is the it's really just a math
problem in the sense that a one dollar
silver coin
does not have the value of one dollar
actually based on current prices that
would increase a legislators pay to
around 4 800 a year which is a violation
of our constitution
that in and of itself makes this bill
unworkable so
that pretty much is the gist of what
happens with
with this
um
you know I
one of the things that was was stated
during testimony was and I wrote it down
was if if people accept something as
money then it is money well
we all accept the US dollar as money and
that's the official legal currency the
United States it's what we've been paid
and what we should continue to be paid
so therefore considering all the factors
this is a this is an easy idea for me
thank you representative Pearson is
there any further discussion
representative wall thank you Mr
chairman all I was going to add to that
is that if we were to be paid in silver
silver coins now weigh a lot less than
they used to
and I can't imagine anyone at any Bank
in New Hampshire or anywhere monitoring
and weighing every single silver coin to
make sure it's exactly what we need they
will have to check the dates on the
coins they'll have to weigh the coins we
will have to carry all those coins I
have no interest in carrying coins thank
you
thank you representative who wants to
um one quick comment one the item that I
made a note for that said Purity
um because coins are not all coins there
are some that um are are higher levels
of Purity and uh therefore more valuable
so just saying you know a certain number
of ounces of silver or a certain number
of coins uh wouldn't wouldn't take it so
um I too would be following the itl
either is there any other further
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the roll
on 245 we're in itl motion okay rep
Sheehan yes
rep Boyd yes
repcoastable yes Mark votes yes rep
Pearson yes
McCarter yeah
reptierney yes rep wall yes rep Notting
Wong yes rep turcott yes
rep Richards yes
yeah he's not here rep payer
and the chair
yes
rep hell what do you want me no that's
fine
[Music]
I would move consent
being any option any opposition to
consent on this being none
okay
you have the blurb
you're the man
um
with that I'll close the exact session
on host Bill 245.
and if you'll give us just a minute to
reset
you ready I'm ready
opening the executive session on House
Bill 301 and recognize representative
Tierney for a motion motion to retain
motion to retain is there a second
second by multiple people uh
uh representative Tierney would you like
yes
this bill we've spoken about talked
about
for two hours this morning
and probably as many hours prior we are
getting closer but we haven't reached
the final spot where everyone's happy so
I think we can do it with subsequent
meetings
thank you representative Terry
representative wall I want to say the
same thing essentially that we're almost
there it won't take a lot longer I don't
think to get to where we need to get so
um I'm assured that we're close enough
that if we have one or two more work
sessions we can make this happen and it
needs to happen thank you
thank you representative wall any
I will just say that I believe
um we are close I believe this is
something that we do need to do
um
I think we just ran up against the
deadline and um
and if we were able to uh perhaps extend
the the season another couple weeks we
would be in in much better shape but it
saddens me to Kick the Can down just uh
a little bit farther down the road but I
think it is for the best rather than to
do something in haste and and have
um stiff opposition when we haven't
thought through all of the unintended
consequences that may occur so with that
um
I will ask the clerk to call the role on
the motion of retain for house bill 301.
okay rep Sheen yes
rep Boyd yes
repcoastable yes clerk votes yes rep
Pearson
yes
Brett McCarter
yeah reptierney yes rep wall yes
rep nutting Wong yes rep turcott yes rep
Richards yes
and rep payer
and chairman Hill
we will retain house bill 301.
um close the exact session on 301 and we
will
um put together
okay and you don't oh okay
and put together
uh the paperwork for house fill eight oh
R6 all right
open the
exact session on hcr6 recognize
representative Constable for emotion
uh thank you Mr chair I move itl on hcr6
able moose itl on house on hcr6 is there
a second
second
is by reptierney
rep constable do you have any discussion
how brief
um thank you
um
I would I would say that you know
condemning the use of violence
um is generally what we would all want
to support
um
however this this bill that came to us
was so broad that any any intent of
self-governing was was included in here
any intent and um it doesn't take it
didn't take me much research to to find
that um there were intensive
self-governing people that was not
justifiable nor Peaceable and I think it
would be a mistake to say that
um just your intent to sort of separate
or be independent of any jurisdiction
um is justifiable and I think it'd be
wrong to say that
um that you
wouldn't be allowed to
um
to no I'd want to use the word violence
because to me it's more of enforcing uh
law right and there are certain examples
that I don't want to get into down the
rabbit hole but on both on the
um there's examples of Chas that was a
couple years ago those were intensive
self-governing and also he had years
prior to that in the 90s paramilitary
groups that also were intensive
self-governing they claimed legitimate
reasons of what they were doing they
believed they were Justified
um and I think it'd be wrong to just
blanket that all of those people
shouldn't be touched just because they
thank you thank you rep Constable
um
reptierney would you like to speak to
in the late 1700s George Washington LED
13 000 federal troops into Western
Pennsylvania to put down the Whiskey
Rebellion
they didn't want to pay a tax
in 1860 we fought a War lasted for five
years
certain people wanted slavery other side
didn't
uh
thank you reptierney any further
discussion
seeing none I will just make one or two
comments here
um we received some testimony during
this uh from
a colleague a past colleague of ours uh
honorable Dan Itza and I just want to
read one two sentences that he wrote The
Power of people to organize a society
hence self-governance is premised on the
situation that they are existing in the
state of nature state of nature exists
when either there is no government or
the government that does exist has so
deviated from its purpose and Charter
that is no longer effectual
close quote um
to me there has been no evidence given
of a situation so dire as to require our
New Hampshire citizens to self-govern
or seek self-governance therefore absent
the conditions when the sponsors feel
this resolution shall be instituted I
see no reason to vote in favor
it does seem ironic that
the sponsors are using the tools of
government to set up restrictions on how
that government can deal with
Insurrection which
I
I guess want in the record
um at any point seeing no further
discussion I'll ask the clerk to call
cr6 the motion of Ito rep Sheen yes
rep Boyd yes
repcoastable yes
or clerk votes yes rep Pearson yes
rep McCarter yeah
rip Tierney yes
rep wall yes rep nothing wrong yes
rep Richards yes
rep cyber
rep uh chair Hill yes
I move consent uh consent's been moved
any
objection
seeing none
that concludes our let me close hcr6
that concludes our work
um I do want to thank rep Siebert uh rep
Perez and rip Boyd for helping us out
um
that concludes our seven bills for for
this year we uh
we're a Dynamo
um so
um we have a number of bills that are
put on consent that is indicative of how
this committee operates
um it's one of cooperation and uh
non-non-partisanship basically
um I appreciate everybody's help I
appreciate
I appreciate that we are able to do our
work efficiently and uh and uh
collegially
um yes representative I have a process
question on the two retained bills are
you imagining that there'll be full
committee
um work sessions again or
um
splitting that in half so maybe fewer
people
get more done
um interesting question I um I honestly
have not even given that a thought it it
won't be
um just just for process for everyone
that's not aware
um these these would be done
um
not until
our work is completed uh at the
legislator probably the budget process
is done is when the speaker allows us to
set up
summer retain building buildings so we
can certainly have that this
conversation I think we'll probably have
it internally from the ranking member
and I
um
what's the what's the pleasure I mean I
it would seem to me we've done pretty
well working on this as a committee of
the whole for especially the ethics
build
um I don't I it may be better and I'm
just on the top of my head thinking that
it may be better to do a subcommittee on
the other one and then come back and and
meet
um
yeah yeah just just so that there may be
recommendations from that subcommittee I
don't
um but at any rate that uh we will be in
touch uh to be determined I guess is the
best way I'm going to say that yep nope
nope question any yep representative
McCarter
yeah
by by you asking
um
um it is uh it could be uh any of those
any or all to without being a smart guy
um
yep
um if there is anyone that specifically
wants to deal on something like that
um I'm just not used to it nobody nobody
ever does those volunteer type things so
um so let's see uh there we go so let's
see how that works um but we certainly
are going to be spending
quite a bit of time together
in reps hall for the next uh
foreseeable future here so I imagine if
there will run into each other if
there's questions along the way feel
free to ask those if there's any
progress in the way I'll make sure that
either
reption or I will let everybody know
but feel free you know our numbers give
us a call and and we'll talk about
anything you want to what about Senate
bills
uh a question was just had on Senate
bills um
I am not privy to anything that's coming
our way
um
yeah are there sent to the I'm not
familiar with the makeup of their
committees I know that they're not
exactly the same as ours so there do
they have a legend admin committee uh
really
um the bills that have come to us in the
past have come from different places and
and obviously everything that comes
across has to be coming through the
filter of the speaker's office and and
sometimes he can send things to us that
he thinks are in our wheelhouse
um but there there is no pipeline you
know as house transportation and Senate
Transportation you know obviously
um so I I really can't answer it I don't
I don't know where to even go bang on
the door and say hey do you have
anything for us
so as soon as I do and as soon as I have
any information uh one or the other of
us will make sure we get in touch and
let people know
all right
um failing that the only thing that it
looks to me like we're going to
potentially have
um
have uh someone speaking Maybe
I guess well I don't know I I have not
heard of anyone pulling anything off
consent or wanting to pull anything off
consent so
um we may be off the hook as far as uh
um that stay tuned I guess is the uh is
the watchword
great thank you very much everyone have
are you doing yeah that's the one for
leadership
so doesn't that tell you all of these
things